I'm going to walk you through what is ChatGPT.
This is the original AI model that everyone knows and loves.
So you've probably heard of it, but we're going to walk you through it anyway.
What would be the next word in the sentence?
The students open their, what?
Could be books, could open their laptops, they could open their exams, their minds.
There's a lot of different words that could come next in that sentence.
And we can predict what word might come next based on the context in
which we're seeing the sentence.
And so can ChatGPT, and that is essentially how these models work.
They have figured out the probability of what word comes next based on all of the
different words that they've seen on the internet.
And, you know, without getting too technical, they have those probabilities
baked into the model and they can decide based on the context, based on
the prompt that you give them, what word comes next.
And they specifically use tokens rather than words.
A token is about three fourths of a word on average, a lot of some differences
in how they split those words up.
But the model is trained until it can predict the next token.
And then when it knows on average what the right tokens are to come next in the
sequence, then you can give it a new sequence and figure out what comes next
after that and through understanding that through being able to predict the next
token, you have to understand quite a lot about how the world works because
you need to know how things are associated.
And therefore we get the magic that is a large language model.
ChancherBT specifically is based on GBT4, which is a transformer model.
Transformer models coming from the attention is all you need paper, which
is a famous paper, but I'm not going to run you through too much of the jargon
here, it won't mean too much to you.
Just need to know is that this is, you know, the current kind of state of
the art of this type of model.
We don't have another type of model other than transformer models
that are doing as good.
But, you know, scientists are working on other types of architecture as well.
So how did they train ChancherBT?
Well, it wasn't just the transformer model that was pretty good on its own.
And that's where we had GBT3, but to get ChancherBT to actually kind of make
it behave like an assistant, we had to have additional steps.
So after training the initial, you know, predict the next token model,
the foundation model, then they had to do some fine tuning on top.
They would have humans figure out which outputs were best and worst
from different questions, and then they would use that to reward the model.
So they would predict tokens that humans thought were good answers to questions.
Then they had to develop a type of policy reward model, PPO, reinforcement
learning, and what that would allow you to do is take a prompt, the sample
from the dataset, use that PPO model to generate the output, and then
the reward model calculates a reward for the output, and the reward is
used to update the policy using PPO.
So this is kind of an additional set of reinforcement learning on top.
Again, technical jargon, but all that means really is that you have the
transformer model that's trained on the internet, then you fine tune it
based on what people find helpful and useful in terms of responses, and
then you optimize it based on policies so that when you get the results,
you can be sure that they're much better on average than what you would
get if you just use the foundation model.
It was created by OpenAI, but you can access it at chat.openai.com or
chatgbt.com.
They have a free version that you can try out and the free version is
pretty comprehensive and generous, but you can also buy a plus or pro
version, the pro version is $200 a month currently, and you get some
additional powerful models for that.
The features are numerous and we're not going to cover all of them here,
but the main things that we find are useful day to day are the chat
history, so being able to see what are the previous chats that you've
had, just the ability to generate text.
So you can ask it for a blog post or explain how the solar system
was made or whatever it is you're trying to generate.
And then also image generation is built into chatgbt through Dali.
It has the ability to browse the web as we can get up to date
current information, which is really powerful.
The models themselves, a little bit confusing.
There's lots of different models and they change all the time, but
broadly speaking, we have GPT-40, which is the workhorse.
You know, they're really good, useful and scalable model that most
people use for most questions.
They have some of the research preview type models like GPT-4.5,
which is a little bit more creative.
And then you have some of the reasoning models like 01, 03 mini, 01
pro mode, and these are the ones where they think first before
giving you a response.
So they're pretty good for mathematical questions or things where you
need a lot of logic.
There's also custom GPTs and you can think of these as custom
prompts where they've given these versions of chatgbt a set of tools
they can use, maybe with the Expedia one, you can book a trip, but
also they have a certain set of instructions tells them how to behave.
Things I use chatgbt for most, I would say creating blog posts.
They have a canvas editor now, which is quite useful.
Creating social media posts, particularly if you want to create
them in a specific style, it's very good at adhering to specific styles.
And then automating tasks as well.
Whenever I need to do something formal, fill in documentation or do my taxes
or peel a parking ticket, then I tend to use chatgbt for that.